it's good to be back here on Turks - as
we call it no because it first you just
made that up
I did did it feel like a family reunion
this time around it does feel like a
little bit of a reunion yeah a lot of a
reunion to be back here I've seen with
the cast with the Turtles and Megan and
joining the family this time around is
Stephen Amell were you a big fan growing
up I was a big turtles fan going up I
definitely saw all three of the turtles
movies from the 90's in the theater
right I knew all the words to the go
ninja go rap gonna go ninja go that's a
little bit what you the plot of this
film
I can't I'm not allowed to say anything
about the plot but I can tell you that
there are well we've got the four
turtles and they're probably already
my character got more handsome oh wow
yeah yeah which is fun tell us a little
bit about your character what can we
expect in this film it's kind of
Canadian rights a hockey mask you have a
hockey stick yeah like there's a scene
where I have to take a couple of slap
shots it feels like oh you play thought
oh yeah yeah of course man I'm Canadian
Will Arnett's here as well another
Canadian how has it been working with
him and Megan Fox Oh working with Will
and Megan is fantastic wills I mean
wills obviously a very funny guy slowly
but surely we're taking over the set